something big is coming to the max space
and I believe that it's going to be the
15 inch MacBook Air and in this video
I'm going to explain why it is the
perfect laptop to come out next year at
the perfect time it's gonna sell like
hotcakes let me explain why but first
I've gotta go through what's been going
on with the Mac space right now in terms
of Apple's market cheer and what's been
coming and what we didn't get and that's
why this 15 inch is going to be such a
big deal check this out we just got this
report that two unreleased Macs have
been spotted in teams database which is
of course a gaming database now out of
those two one of them is the Mac 14
comma 6 identifier and the other one is
the Mac 15 4 both listed with zero
percent usage on steam's platform now if
you didn't already know that Mac 14 6
has already been seen in some other
leaks specifically that's actually the
M2 Max geekbench scores which have been
leaked multiple times we recently just
got another updated one that broke 2 000
single core score as you can see right
here 2027 which is actually really good
which makes us think we might actually
get four nanometer chips but as you can
see right here going down into the
identifiers Mac
14-6 so that is one of the leaked theme
database Mac models and now of course
for the other one the Mac 15 4 I believe
that that's going to be the 15 inch M2
MacBook Air and I'll explain why in just
a minute now I want to bring you to this
report from Apple where they said that
Mac Revenue would decline substantially
year over year in the December quarter
now there's a couple of reasons for that
first of all everybody was expecting new
Macbook Pros the 14 and 16 inch models
with the M2 Pro and M2 Max chips but of
course we didn't get that we didn't even
get a November Apple event at all and so
many people were waiting on those new
models but they got delayed of course
until I believe March 2023 when those
are coming out and of course now that we
have these awesome benchmarks with up to
3.68 gigahertz base frequency over 2 000
single core score it makes sense why
people are gonna hold off to buy a new
Macbook and Frederick orange on Twitter
believes that it makes the most sense
for these new MacBooks to come with four
nanometer chips the same as a16 because
we definitely don't want five nanometer
people aren't gonna buy those I'll
explain why people already aren't buying
those expensive 14 and 16 inches but
four nanometer is what we would want now
the reason why we probably won't get
three nanometer right now is because
three nanometer is brand new it's only
going to be coming early next year into
some products but the chip wafers
themselves are 25 more expensive for
Apple than five nanometers so I guess it
makes sense that during a recession
which we're entering right now Apple
probably wants to delay three nanometer
as long as I can so we might get that
four nanometer and now in my opinion
even with four nanometer coming to those
new M2 Pro and M2 Max chips I still
don't think those MacBook Pros are going
to be selling that well because the
design is going to be unchanged it's set
in stone where most likely only going to
have internal changes and that's simply
not enough to get a lot of people to buy
them but another reason why I don't
expect them to do that well and why I
think we need a 15 inch MacBook Air
coming next year in the spring is
because of this poll that was made in
October 19th of
2021. the MacBook Pro's new price is too
high for 97 of buyers yes yougov direct
did a poll on behalf of Digital Trends
and check this out they pulled a
thousand 116 people on the highest
amount that they'd be willing to spend
on a new laptop and according to the
poll just three percent of people are
willing to spend two thousand dollars or
more on a laptop and yes the 14 inch
base model the cheapest 14 inch new one
starts at two thousand dollars that
means that only three percent of people
are willing to buy it basically it's a
niche market where you really have to
find the right buyer to spend at least
two thousand dollars or twenty five
hundred on a 16 inch and this was before
all of the recession talk and everything
kind of going down economically Imagine
Next Year where we might have a bad
recession how many people are going to
be buying these I don't think that many
which is why I believe it makes perfect
sense for Apple to release the 15-inch
MacBook Air so let's get into those
leaks now now the reason I believe it's
going to be so important for Apple to
release this 15 inch is because it all
comes down to what happened in 2021 Mac
shipments more than doubled in first
three months of 2021 compared to the
same period in 2020 and that was of
course right after the M1 ship was
released and it was an absolute Banger
because of the low entry level price of
that MacBook Air a thousand dollars made
available to so many people of course
not like the two thousand dollar plus 14
and 16 inch models and guess what
happened this year Apple sees falling
iPad sales and fiscal 2022 but Max sales
are up that was on October 27
2022 and why did that happen well
because that was right after Apple
released the M2 MacBook Air which a lot
of people loved actually look at these
tweets from people I've been using my
new Macbook Air for two weeks now and
it's an absolute Delight the M2 is
blazingly fast and every time I pick it
up I get a little jolt of surprise at
how thin and light it is yes it is
incredibly thin and light unlike any
other laptop out there check out this
tweet from Ian zelbo these are the
laptops I see at College in order of
popularity the first one is the 13-inch
M2 MacBook Air and that was only a
couple of months after they were
released so they're gaining popularity
very quickly and look at this guy's
tweet M2 perform Performance Plus new
great front-facing camera plus great
battery life with fast charging equals
College laptop of your dreams and I
completely agree especially since right
now you can get it on sale on Amazon for
a thousand fifty dollars that's a
hundred and fifty bucks off MSRP only 50
bucks more than people were buying the
M1 MacBook Air and this is arguably a
much better designed laptop just look at
those bezels so it's an excellent deal
right now so it makes sense why college
students are buying them so here's the
point that I want to make How can Apple
save their Max sales during a recession
well they release a new 15-inch MacBook
Air now check out these leaks from Mark
German June 9th that was right after
WWDC when they released the 13-inch
MacBook gear said Apple plans a 15 inch
MacBook Air for next year and looking
more specifically at the actual
Bloomberg article he said that Apple
plans 15 inch MacBook gear for
2023 and looking even more closely he
says it could release as early as next
spring which to me points at March
2023 the perfect time for Apple's March
event to release a 15-inch MacBook Air
now we also had leaks from Bros Young
Who perfectly gets the display size of
the M2 MacBook Air saying it would go up
to 13.6 inches that was back in March
and he is saying that the 15-inch
MacBook gear will actually be
15.2 inches and that makes a lot of
sense because right now the 14-inch
MacBook Pro is actually 14.2 inches and
that extra 0.2 inches accounts for the
notch which of course the 15 inch M2
MacBook Air would also have so this
makes perfect sense and then on top of
that Ross young also said that the
display would be missing out on Mini Led
Tech technology so it's going to be
basically the same LCD Tech as we
already have in the M2 MacBook Air now
with that said let's put all of those
leaks together first of all if we do get
a 15 inch MacBook Air in early 2023 in
the spring let's say March that is too
early for the M3 chip which means that
we're essentially going to get the same
M2 Chip we already have in the current
13 inch M2 MacBook Air so it's going to
be identical the same chip the same
internals everything but instead of 13
inch it's going to be a 15 inch model
with the same exact LCD display
technology however because of the extra
internal space you're going to get a
bigger battery much bigger actually and
Apple's going to Market it as the best
battery life in any MacBook ever it's
going to be absolutely insane with of
course the M2 Chip performance and a
larger display which is awesome for a
lot of people who right now they want a
bigger display but they can't afford
twenty five hundred dollars for a 16
inch MacBook Pro just like we saw from
that poll only three percent of people
were willing to spend over two thousand
dollars so what do you do during a
recession you release a 15-inch MacBook
Air with the same exact M2 Chip for
fifteen hundred dollars where a lot of
people can afford it and it basically
just blows up people love it especially
if it's the same thickness as it is
right now which is incredibly thin right
now but if you make it 15 inches it's
gonna seem even more thin impossibly
thin and because of the larger display
size the notch is gonna seem smaller and
the bezels are gonna seem smaller as
well and on top of that they can also
make the speakers better with actual
speaker grilles like we have on this 16
inch MacBook Pro on the new 15 inch so
you essentially make an awesome awesome
laptop 15 inches big display for those
people in the mass Market who can afford
to spend fifteen hundred dollars on a
laptop this is gonna be a great seller
especially during a recession and that
is why I believe that this extra mac
model number in the steam database is
pointing to the 15 inch M2 MacBook Air
now if you totally disagree with me let
me know down in the comment section
below but if you love this idea and
you're willing to wait until spring to
see what happens click the circle about
to subscribe for more videos like this
one definitely check out the product
link to the current M2 MacBook Air using
YouTube's product link tagging feature
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign